they're the most dangerous
extreme weather phenomena
heatwaves basically affect our bodies
and the ecosystems around us and they
send us to the hospital or they kill us
this is europe's first chief heat
officer her task is to find ways to
protect citizens from the dangerous
effects of extreme heat
as the climate warms and the frequency
of heat waves dramatically increases
cities are appointing people like her to
limit the dangers
we talked to three of them to find out
how we can best deal with this new
normal
what's coming our way and what can we do
to protect ourselves
i started thinking of what i have to do
in three pillars the first pillar has to
do with raising awareness how do we
communicate and get people to take this
seriously many of us aren't aware of
just how dangerous heat can be because
heat is a silent killer
we don't see the effects of extreme heat
as visibly as the physical destruction
brought by hurricanes flux and other
natural disasters
but extreme heat now kills up to half a
million people worldwide each year
that's more than all other natural
disasters that aren't due to the
temperature
and the problem is getting worse
especially in cities which are heating
up at twice the global average rate
because they trap heat more than
non-urban areas
this is going to be one of the coolest
summers that we're going to have
for the rest of our lives and that's not
something that we should take lightly we
really have to understand that cities
are really
hot spots they're not going to be able
to be viable in a few decades
by 2100 cities across the world could
warm as much as 4.4 degrees celsius on
average so how do officials best sound
the alarm and make sure people
understand the gravity of the situation
one of the things that we've done for
raising awareness which i think is
really a game changer is we have been
categorizing heat waves for the first
time in athens this year it's a pilot
project that was started in cv spain and
athens greece and will be adopted by
other cities soon it categorizes seed
waves based on the effect on human
health much like earthquakes get
categorized based on the intensity the
idea is to help people prepare and
respond better
and that's not all heat waves will also
be named in the future just like
hurricane katrina immediately evokes
these images in your head and makes it
easier to remember the disaster so may
heatwave zoe the world's first ever heat
event to officially be named ncvi at the
end of july
once it's clear that a heat wave is
especially dangerous information on how
to stay safe can be spread to those who
are most endangered messaging around
heat waves is is really critical because
there are a lot there's a lot people can
do with their own behavior
to keep them safer the city of athens
even developed an extreme heat app
that's now also being used in milan
paris and rotterdam
we have an application called extrema
global that shows you your personalized
risk depending where you are in the city
and your age and your gender and whether
you are you're you have pre-existing
conditions
and tells you also on the map where to
go to take cover where the cool spots
are around you
in a similar effort africa's first heat
officer is currently creating a heat map
for the city of freetown
what we're trying to do is to understand
where are the hot spots um where are the
urban heat island to back the plan and
prioritize resources
resources in sierra leone are limited so
eugenia carbo wants to focus on helping
the most vulnerable people first that
includes female vendors who are exposed
to the sun all day when selling their
produce in uncovered markets without any
shade so what we've done is to work
together with those women and design a
project which we call the market shade
cover project basically we use a
material that is heat reflective that
doesn't absorb the heat to provide a
shade cover for the women
the project will be implemented and
launched within the next few months just
even seeing the joy on their face like
when i was talking to them about the
project and gave me hope that
definitely there's something that can be
done
to help save lives and help improve the
living condition of people who are the
most vulnerable
on a larger scale the design of entire
cities can evolve to beat the heat
one of the solutions that athens has
been trying to implement
a lot of cities have tried to implement
around the world is creating green
corridors
and we have finalized the designs of
three green corridors in athens
meanwhile freetown is currently cleaning
up garbage sites and converting them
into public gardens that are clean safe
and cool
they're also planting a million trees
across the city so that free tongue
eventually becomes treetown
santiago de chile is taking a similar
approach we just found a two million
dollar urban forest program
it's it's a really ambitious initiative
that aims to provide with at least 30
thousand
trees for the city we never had that in
the past before
trees don't just provide shade and
reflect the sun's rays back up they also
help lower the air temperature around
them by essentially sweating they take
up water from the ground which then gets
put back into the air through a process
called evapotranspiration
but they aren't the only form of
vegetation that can help cool down the
air
in places where there might not be
enough space for new trees streets and
roofs can also be greened
cities across the world from paris to
london bangkok to singapore have started
incorporating green roofs or living
walls in their urban architecture
and santiago de chile is looking to do
the same they're about to start building
a cool roof on a public building
we know that green roofs it can
promote provide many benefits like
pulling down the the buildings saving
energy but also
helping people to look some green it can
help with their mental health and also
provide a little of bio diversity within
the city so we are doing the first one
in september and the idea is to measure
everything in order to escape that
project to the rest of the city in the
near future
experts believe cities also have to
change the way they construct new
buildings to adapt to the heat in the
future our cities are built primarily
with materials that absorb solar energy
that are impermeable to water so we
don't get the sort of evaporative
benefits and so we basically designed
our cities to trap heat and that's what
they're doing
using nature-based materials with high
solar reflectance is one idea another is
going back to using light colored
materials for the outside of buildings
from walls to roofs something that
southern europe has been doing for a
long time and now other cities across
the globe can adapt that idea we have a
lot of informal communities people
who live in houses built from zinc so
maybe that's a starting point seeing how
we can um
provide
um white paints and um just
it's it's it's kind of a basic solution
but the impact is immense
of course climate change caused by
carbon emissions is the real driver of
extreme heat
we have to drastically cut our
greenhouse gas emissions in order to
prevent a catastrophic level of global
warming but experts say that even then
so much damage has already been done
that we'll also have to learn to adapt
projections show that things are only
getting worse from here
that's why we are addressing the the
problem now in order to prepare us for
the future we know that preparedness it
takes time and we is we don't need to
wait until a disaster or a heat wave
hits us on in the face in order to
prepare for that the good news is
there's a lot we can do and we have it
at our fingertips we don't this is less
an innovation problem and more of an
adoption problem
and that means we can do something
quickly about it if we put our minds
you